will tell you as a father I know from
raising my son that he needs both me and
his mother in his life so I so when
someone who hasn't had children is
telling me Oh no kids don't need they're
both their parents I find it laughable
because because I tell you something
most parents will tell you that they
know that their child needs both parents
in their life for you to say something
like that makes no sense to me as a
parent it doesn't make any sense I have
kids in my family that will raise single
parents and whatever or some kids in
care and stuff like that I feel like
it's laughable that you just said oh my
my life is this so you're wrong
he's saying my life is this and stats
back it up my statistics about what the
results are at the end of this because
the way you're going it's just like I
believe what I believe regardless of any
stats so you could see whatever stat and
you're still gonna think what you think
yeah because I think you can't
generalize anything in the world I don't
think anything can be generalized
like unless you're a therapist giving
specific advice like I think people are
too individual to even you said you
can't generally you can't say women are
this you can't say so-and-so is out you
can't say children
prefer milk
you can't say anything what do you mean
you can't generate I never I don't say
anything I don't say women are this or
dogs of that or whatever is this I just
say that thing there is this and that's
it and I don't feel I don't I don't
travel do dogs bark
some don't much
but actually this is a thing that so now
you would just argue just to be right in
in a conversation because you know dogs
bark but for you to say oh some don't
it's like you know that that's what then
you can't argue anything you can't argue
yeah so you get like if you don't if you
can't generalize at all then you can't
argue anything
I'll take that back and I will just say
we can't generalize men and women and
families I also think there's a
difference between ideal and realism
like the reality of people's situations
exactly I think a lot of women would
love to be married but they're real
realistically but they made poor choices
maybe they did get married and maybe it
was a bad time you know you never know
the situation but being a single mom is
a lot of work especially if you have
like three kids yeah
so I'm saying like don't so don't pick
it so don't pick it that's a choice yeah
you don't end up with a single mom by
accident like and you choose who you
sleep with with
I don't know I think well maybe if that
husband was better she wouldn't have
left
why is it okay maybe if she was ready
maybe maybe if she was better she
wouldn't have left I think if they both
worked on it then yeah I think we can
both agree people should work on their
relationships before Calling it Quits
but there's you know there's reality
there's a reality and ideal listen I
think women should get should be more
Discerning when deciding which members
okay but women have only recently earned
like over the last like 20 30 years
right which isn't a long time period in
the grand scheme as being especially
generation it's two generations
I'm a woman what does that have to do
with me today woman had to rely on men
for like you said financial support to
be able to work to be able to live
essentially and as we've come out of
that yes it's been what like 40 50 years
right as we've come probably a bit
longer no about 50 60 years to say that
and and they had to rely on settling to
be able to get a man to be able to
support them so we are still shifting
out of that mindset where you you settle
for something that maybe isn't that
great because you have to be supported
you have to have this nuclear family
situation I grew up with two parents in
the house I grew up with a relative you
know two parents who were incredibly
functioning Society but I was suicidal
by the time I was 12. so it doesn't
having two parents doesn't blink at
least assume that you're going to be
happy like those statistics that you
read off it's not necessarily because
the kid had a single mother there's so
many different systemic issues that go
into that poverty you know where you
live like different aspects it's not
just about having a single mother I've
got a question for you yes all the girls
on the panel
um so I learned this a couple weeks ago
that women are very picky when it comes
to men my question is if you were given
the choice
would you marry a guy you're not
attracted to knowing that he's going to
stay in the relationship and Paul feel
free to rephrase my question if you feel
I'm saying it wrong or
so would you marry a guy that you're not
attracted to but you know he's going to
stay there he's going to provide and
everything oh would you marry the guy
that's cheated multiple times but you
are madly in love with him who would you
be with that's a boundary I'll go first
personally I would say neither and
because I've been in both of those
situations where I've had someone who
would be a perfect option but I wasn't
attracted to them and I've had someone
that I've been madly in love with who
[__] around with me essentially I've
been in both those situations and I
think the issue is people have to think
they have to settle for those situations
so which one neither neither
I'm sorry I don't know if it's a cop-out
but I wouldn't choose either I'm not
doing I would I would rather be on my
own all right if those reminds you if
you could give me one if a life on the
line one I would choose the one I'm not
attracted to cool
me too okay yep
I think I also have to say neither I'm
not somebody who's ever necessarily if
your life is on the line if your life is
on the line pick one I'd rather die
honestly like the way you guys are
answering like that's why 50 of women
over 30 are single and childless right
yeah because they want to be it's a
decision it's it's not necessarily
because they're also the least happy
group when they hit like 45 or 50.
correct because like the party runs out
someday someday no one's lining up to
date you at a certain age yeah and it's
not really a decision because the guys
are the ones who control who gets
relationships I mean from what I can see
it seems like the Crux is you need to
understand it just because you don't
like your options doesn't mean you
should Gaslight yourself but you're
believing you don't have any you know
like right yeah and your options are
just that's your level so like if you if
you don't like the guys you can date
then like you should probably try to
improve yourself but yeah and I
completely agree with that I believe you
should work onto yourself until you're
ready to be in a relationship that you
want and that's why I would rather be
alone until I'm ready for a relationship
that's going to be reciprocal in all
ways and I think that's the mindset it
shouldn't be about whether people can a
self-relationship or anything like this
people should be open to working on
themselves be open to like not being
judgmental do you think do you think
about love do you think at a certain age
though it's kind of just like okay like
like let's say 32. you only really have
till 35 if you want to have kids and you
don't have because geriatric pregnancy
is like 20 000 a year so the average
person can't afford that if you want a
family and you want kids you think
there's a certain age where you kind of
look around and be like you know what I
don't think my options are going to get
better than this because I'm just
getting older
I think yes and no because I A lot of
times like when we say subtle like maybe
he's settling for her
like how can we just say women are
settling when that's your level I think
that's like saying a guy saying oh I
didn't get a Victoria's Secret model so
I settled
yeah I think I think I think okay but
that's I think settling for appearance
is different in terms of selling for the
way someone behaves so the way someone
treats you if you're settling for
someone who doesn't treat you the way
you deserve to be treated who isn't
present who doesn't show up or treats
you the way you want to be treated then
you're settling for yourself and I think
every I think the idea is that we have
limited options which we don't so if
everyone is attracted to different
things yeah so if women if women hate
um men that don't treat them right right
then why do we all seem to date them
correct uh trauma generational trauma a
whole bunch of stuff a whole so many
different things no it's not an excuse
me it's genuinely what's going on women
are attracted to Bad Boys
generally women are attracted to bad
boys so women see red flags in men
um they see a certain type of man
generally I'm not so we know it's not
all women yeah and they still go for
that type of man do you know that
attachment Theory by any chance how we
pursue relationships find us of our
earliest it's like anxious anxious
attached like that sort of thing right
so especially in terms of like anxious
attachment and that sort of thing you
tend to seek relationships where even if
someone's treating you negatively you
think you're the problem so you do
anything you can to change yourself to
match that behavior and that's why women
stay in relationships because they have
this self-deprecating view of themselves
in security I wouldn't say broken I
don't like the word broken well because
that's what position
I would say no but I would make that
point I don't think Society is broken I
don't I think unhealed and broken are
very different things
you don't think if you keep dating bad
partner after bad partner like maybe
it's you maybe do you know how maybe the
trauma goes for someone to constantly
put themselves in that situation where
they constantly make the wrong choice so
deep and that can be so subconscious
it's so difficult to consciously bring
to mind if you don't have the right
people talking about it right there or
you could just make better like yeah
like an excuse even if it is an excuse
It's a genuine excuse that people deal
with people not really at the end I have
an anxious an anxious attachment style
but I'm not I'm not going to blame that
on my poor choices like but I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna say that was a poor
choice and I'm gonna learn from it I'm
not gonna say oh that's right on your
childhood but yeah like no I mean I
could I could I could do a whole sob
story behind ten siblings you can
acknowledge the poor choice and still
like see that you can make better to
some people just can't see that or you
could just say oh this is a poor choice
this is on me this is my fault I'm gonna
move on some people don't have the
ability to be able to do everything
everyone has the ability
so deeply I'm gonna say yes but I don't
like the word broken I see on here
broken women broken Society but it's not
just broken woman it's broken man it's
broken people no but it's not just
broken woman okay so you're talking
about anxious attachment attachment
style yeah we're talking about uh women
who choose men yeah right when women
choose men men women have babies by
these men right so like well generally
women are having babies right so if
they're choosing these men having babies
by these men what are these children
going to be that's what I'm saying what
are these children going to be like
because the next Generation that is
going to be raised in this Society the
Next Generation that matters in the
society is the children okay and so like
I said if the women aren't if the women
are broken
you are going to raise a broken Society
the men are involved in that too yeah
hang on but you were telling me that
it's okay to raise a child without a man
yeah old men are involved but you don't
want the man involved no I'm not saying
so what we do in here
what we doing are we are we raising
nuclear families or are we do are we
doing a whole single mother thing are we
are we being broken I'll be raising
broken children what are we doing I
don't understand how women are broken
because they choose bad men so that
means broken Society but women are bad
men they're just being chose the bad men
are there that's the subject
but the majority of men are are good men
oh it's a very it's a very no it's a
very small percentage of men that are
sleeping with all the women like it's a
very like if you want a guy that's over
six foot that's 15 a man you wanted to
be cute cut that in half you want to
make money cut that in half it's a very
small percentage of men that are
sleeping with all the girls like every
girl has a guy in their friend zone that
would treat them well and they know
likes them and it's like we don't pick
them and then we're gonna cry because
the guy we picked is bad to us but you
could have picked the guy in the friend
zone